para ver con ustedes de un tema que he
venido trabajando hace algunos años y
que creo que además es quizás muy
significativo para todos porque es un
tema que ocupa gran parte de nuestra
vida quizá es la tercera parte de
nuestra que no la pasamos en el trabajo
y el trabajo es un asunto importante
porque
lo que hemos encontrado es que puede ser
una experiencia que nos lleve a la
condición de vivir placenteramente o por
el contrario nos podría llevar a una
experiencia de mucho sufrimiento o
quizás de algo de malestar entonces
estoy aquí para hablarles de cuáles
serían las condiciones que podríamos
estar viviendo hoy de cómo el mundo se
transformó y cambió en los últimos años
después de 1973 y cómo esos cambios
pueden estar afectando nuestra
experiencia emocional en el trabajo
lo que podemos decir entonces para
empezar la tesis central es tenemos un
mundo del trabajo y tenemos una
actividad que nos toma mucho tiempo de
la vida que puede tener una doble
valencia por un lado el trabajo puede
ser una experiencia liberadora
emancipador y realizadora en nosotros
como seres humanos pero también por otro
lado el trabajo podría ser algo que nos
esclaviza algo que lo subordina algo que
nos podría representar sufrimiento la
condición actual nos ha llevado
exactamente a una condición no muy
favorable y es que experimentamos cada
vez mayor nivel de malestar en el
trabajo la pregunta que entonces podemos
hacernos es porque experimentamos cada
vez más malestar en el trabajo
contemporáneo y aquí tendríamos algunas
condiciones que plantear pero la primera
que podríamos plantear es bueno y que
podríamos entender por malestar cierto
porque además lo he nombrado y lo
nombrado seguido de otra palabra es
cierto otro concepto que es el de
sufrimiento hay una diferencia en la
experiencia subjetiva de estas dos
dimensiones una cosa
estar entendido como una experiencia de
tensión psíquica que tiene un carácter y
es que es difusa y determinada pero
también es desgastante la particularidad
del malestar es que es un estado de
tensión pero es indeterminada no sabemos
exactamente por qué digamos
experimentamos ese estado de tensión
pero sin duda como es una experiencia de
tensión es desgastante para nosotros
emocionalmente el malestar en el trabajo
sería esa experiencia de tensión difusa
e indeterminada que es bastante y que
está asociada a la experiencia de
trabajar y lo que tenemos hoy en día es
que los estudios nos están mostrando y
cada vez lo vemos más yo cada vez soy
llamado cierto por personas
frecuentemente que quiere hablar conmigo
porque experimentan algún nivel de
malestar lo que podemos decir entonces
es que tenemos una tendencia a una
generalización del malestar cierto como
una experiencia subjetiva en el trabajo
una experiencia emocional relacionada
con el trabajo y también tenemos una
profundización del sufrimiento eso para
decir que no todo en el trabajo sufrimos
pero que algunos que sufrimos estamos
experimentando un sujeto cada vez más
intenso
pero qué es el sufrimiento entonces para
diferenciarlo en este sentido de esa
otra categoría que ha nombrado el
surgimiento puede ser entendido como una
experiencia también de desgaste cierto
es una también tensión ante
emocionalmente pero cuya condición
central es quedaría sin sentido el
sufrimiento es una experiencia de
tensión derivada encontrarle sentido a
lo que hacemos y esto no tiene que ver
solamente con el mundo del trabajo
cuando por ejemplo tenemos una pérdida
amorosa el sufrimiento se refiere a que
tenemos una experiencia de tensión
porque no entendemos por qué pasó es
cierto o sea no entedemos porque se nos
ha muerto por ejemplo a una mascota y a
pesar que sabemos racionalmente que se
ha muerto por una razón clínica no
aceptamos fácilmente que sea que se haya
muerto o en el caso de una pérdida
amorosa nos preguntamos bueno y por qué
para qué pasó porque ese fue cierto y
salen las preguntas de qué tiene el que
no tenga yo cierto y cómo es en qué
lugar se enamoró de ti de dónde
es aquella el tiempo libre esas
dimensiones lo que están diciendo es
hacemos preguntas a las que intentamos
encontrarle un sentido a lo que está
pasando con nosotros emocionalmente
cuando no encontramos sentido entonces
esa experiencia es una experiencia
intensa que produce una condición de
sufrimiento hagamos una metáfora para
que entiendan la diferencia entre
experimentar malestar y experimentar
sufrimiento
el malestar es natural le da cuando
tiene gripa pero el sufrimiento es lo
que le da cuando tiene un cólico cierto
la cosa y ya no es tan tolerable es
mucho más intensa y le obliga a tener
que hacer algo necesariamente en el
trabajo podríamos estar experimentando
en términos generales más o menos
ampliamente una experiencia de malestar
pero algunos tienen efectivamente una
experiencia de sufrimiento y de beso lo
que los psicólogos clínicos del trabajo
nos ocupamos de pensar por qué personas
están experimentando el trabajo como una
condición de sufrimiento
lo que podría siento así es que hay dos
fuentes del malestar o incluso del
sufrimiento unas que son de carácter
objetivo que son las condiciones
materiales y simbólicas también las
condiciones relacionales en las que
desarrollamos el trabajo y otras que son
las condiciones singulares esas que
tienen que ver con cómo es cada uno de
nosotros en su particularidad como
individuo esta combinación podría ser
una combinación digamos que si es
demasiado distante es una situación que
nos produce mucho malestar digamos de
esta manera en la mente hay un desfase
más amplio entre lo que son las
condiciones objetivas de lo que esperan
el trabajo y lo que yo soy como sujeto
cierto y lo que yo espero ese desfase
mayor podría producir mayor nivel de
tensión y por supuesto mayor nivel de
malestar o incluso de sufrimiento
digamos entonces qué condiciones podrían
estar en el lado del objetivo que
podríamos estar podrían estar
determinando que experimentamos el mundo
del trabajo como un mundo no siempre tan
agradable por un lado tenemos una
condición específica que la
fragmentación laboral en la cual la
fragmentación del mundo del trabajo
produce precarización del trabajo y esa
aplicación el trabajo produce una
emoción muy particular y es la sensación
de estar en condición de riesgo no
tenemos la certeza de que vamos a tener
siempre el trabajo que en cualquier
momento podríamos ser echados o que
quizás nos van a contratar y no hay nada
que asuste más a un sujeto que trabaja
que la condición del desempleo y el
desempleo son la situación que se vive
de una manera muy angustiante
particularmente porque el trabajo no
solamente es un problema de ganar dinero
el trabajo no es solamente un problema
de producir trabajar es también
construir una identidad trabajar también
es definir un lugar en el mundo
generalmente cuando nos presentamos
cierto ante nosotros decimos en primer
instancia nuestro nombre y generalmente
después lo que decimos es nuestra
ocupación es decir que el trabajo nos
provee
es importante y es la identidad cuando a
menos sentimos amenazados la pérdida de
todo lo que sentimos amenazadas la
posibilidad tener una entidad en este
mundo socialmente activo lo segundo es
que hay una presión muy fuerte entre los
iguales esta presión entre iguales es
derivada de una condición siguiente que
es que hay una situación de fuerte
individualización de la relación de
trabajo la gente está muy preocupada por
triunfar por sí misma y eso implica
entonces que hagan cosas como la
siguiente es una es que acarrean
demasiado lo que hace cierto se andan
diciendo que todo el tiempo lo demás que
lo que están haciendo no les llega un
correo por ejemplo una cosa tiene un
culo de luis y yo que tengo que ver con
eso porque me dio forma a mí porque está
en juego estratégico está en el hueco
estratégico de promocionarse a sí mismo
de similares como yo trabajo mire como
soy debo de no mire como soy de
importante porque él siente el miedo de
ser expulsado desde en el trabajo y es
una manera de protegerse las el mundo es
que entonces aumenta el nivel del
control sobre los compañeros andan
mirando constantemente en ejercicios que
operamos regular decir es un ejercicio
de debilidad y criticar cierto todo el
tiempo anda diciendo
pero se equivoca la regula demasiada es
una manera que el neutraliza que el otro
pueda salir un poco más adelante porque
está en la relación de competencia el
problema es que esa relación de
competencia produce un efecto de
individualización y entonces
experimentamos el mundo del trabajo cada
vez más solos cierto pero también el
mundo la universidad
quizás la indolencia no sea solamente un
problema de atrás sino que es un
problema de las relaciones sociales
contemporáneas y esta condición de
soledad hace que experimentamos el
trabajo conocí la posibilidad de
experimentar en él la posibilidad de la
amistad
enrico el bien es un autor francés dice
en el mundo el trabajo de los amigos no
existen más cierto es muy difícil tener
amigos porque la relación de competencia
disminuye otras posibilidades
por otro lado tenemos la intensificación
laboral y es este hecho tener que
trabajar cada vez más cierto con cada
vez menos hay menos recursos para
trabajar y esta condición provisión una
tele es generalmente asociada y en la
invisibilización laboral tenemos que
trabajar en espacio donde no nos están
viendo como diría la canción de es tan
cierto trabajamos cuando nadie nos ve y
esa es una condición que
tiene un efecto muy fuerte y es que va a
debilitar una condición que el trabajo
necesita para poder mantenerse afilado
como herramienta y es el reconocimiento
cuando usted no lo ven lo que hace usted
pierde las posibilidades de que lo
trates tigo ese esfuerzo y por lo tanto
lo reconozca pero como hay dos
condiciones que están en juego es que
estamos en competencia pero además
trabajamos fuera del mundo del trabajo
fuera de la escena laboral formal
entonces tenemos un problema es que no
obtenemos la recompensa simbólica que es
el reconocimiento y por otro lado
tenemos una situación muy complicada de
manejar tenemos que trabajar el reino de
la contradicción los jefes nos dicen que
pero nos dicen cómo y menos con qué
cierto y esa es una situación que
problematiza en la situación de trabajo
porque nos pone en la presencia tiene
que resolver el trabajo a veces de
manera muy precaria
pero adicionalmente tenemos en el mundo
social más amplio cuatro culturas que
van a intensificar las situaciones de
malestar por una vez tenemos una cultura
y la urgencia que es la dictadura del
tiempo rápido del tiempo acelerado en la
cual sentimos que todo el tiempo estamos
un día atrás de donde queríamos estar
cierto que el tiempo alcanza no es
suficiente que estamos siempre un poco
atrasados que no queríamos entregar los
segundos que trabajan oculto del
narcisismo en la cual la globalización
es mucho más fuerte y sobre una cultura
más o menos legítima en la que primero
yo
segundo yo tercero yo y eso está muy
bien para el yo pero está muy mal para
las versiones con el otro lo tercero es
un culto a la imagen cierto una cosa que
ha denunciado un autor que es muy devota
que dice estamos en la sociedad el
espectáculo cierto todos foto para el
facebook en el mundo del trabajo también
eso funciona y hay una condición en la
cual todo lo que hacemos con un valor de
espectacularidad todo lo que tenemos
hacer lo quería mostrar para nosotros
como un asunto simplemente interesante
que tiene mucho ahora porque estamos en
el juego estratégico de la competencia
hacernos visibles hacernos más
empleables
finalmente hay una condición que es muy
fuerte y es el club del desempeño el
éxito el éxito como excesivamente
sacralizado tenemos que entonces ya con
tiempo ser exitosos y si nos basamos en
todo experimentando sensaciones por una
culpa en alcanzar el éxito pero por otro
si le tenemos mucho temor de perder lo
que somos del rendimiento estamos
obsesionados con rendir pero también
entonces tenemos un efecto son una socia
del cansancio y por lo tanto del dopaje
que significa el dopaje que para poder
hacer alcanzar las metas de la
productividad la intensidad digamos de
trabajo que nos piden tenemos que
reactivar psicoactivos algunos que usan
los más fuertes como la marihuana la
cocaína otro más útil es cierto como el
vives y en cierto del redbull o incluso
el café esa es una manera también de
activar psicológicamente para poder
rendir ante las exigencias que nos hace
el mundo del trabajo en temporal bien
hasta ahí les conté la parte externa
la parte interna es decir la que tiene
que reconocer los conciertos de la otra
parte que también puede ser la
determinante porque sufrimos en el mundo
del trabajo digamos que estamos ante el
efecto de la denegación con un
determinante subjetivo de la experiencia
del malestar por un lado tenemos la
negación de los trabajadores como
sujetos de deseo qué significa eso que
muchas veces estamos forzados a trabajar
en condiciones en las que lo que hacemos
no nos apasiona y no tenemos suficiente
autonomía
muchas veces horarios rigurosos que no
nos permiten hacer el trabajo en el
ritmo subjetivo que para nosotros sería
el más indicado los profesores
universitarios por ejemplo sobre mucho
cuando les pueden horarios rígidos
porque ahora siempre producción
artículos sentado en la oficina una vez
se lo produce al lado de la mañana otro
de tomar un café y comenzar a escribir
radio de la noche y terminará a las tres
de la mañana pero no lo hace en el día
pero si tiene que ir a la empresa puede
no estar trabajando en el día y después
trabajando en la noche uno debería
entender que ese ritmo de producción es
singular y que personas que trabajan sin
necesidades en la oficina
y que cumple con su meta sin necesidad
que sean vistos lo que tenemos entonces
está bien es que además de que muchas
veces estamos trabajando una cosa que no
tiene nada que ver con lo que nos gusta
con lo que deseamos
tenemos un problema derivado lo que les
conté hace unos momentos cómo tenemos
relaciones de fuerte competencia pero
también de alta y normalización tenemos
una experiencia mutua negación del
reconocimiento estamos que estamos
trabajando bajo un régimen de la
indiferencia y de la poca solidaridad es
muy difícil reconocer al otro muy
difícil decirle que bien que lo hiciste
nos cuesta dificultad porque eso es
interpretado como una ventaja
competitiva que se le algo al colega y
en el mismo sentido entonces procuramos
evitarlo pero hay un problema
los sujetos necesitamos comunes como una
condición fundamental en la existencia y
reconocidos el reconocimiento es una
experiencia de afirmación del otro han
sentido alguna vez esa incomodidad de
experimentar sentarse o pararse al lado
de otro al lado de un ascensor
poderlo saludar o no saludarlo o que no
salga usted esa experiencia a malú acá
es lo que yo les digo es una experiencia
de tensión psíquica cierto son aso dice
porque no nos saludamos cierto nadie se
explica porque nada pero ninguno de este
modo la iniciativa de hacerlo es martín
además cuando es algo y el otro no
contesta la cosa es peor todavía cierto
formica ahora ya usted no espacio pero
no fue capaz de recíprocamente
devolverle el saludo que es el primer
signo de reconocimiento social
lo más curioso
sabe que yo estaba aquí pero no se había
arriesgado a reconocerlo bien en estas
dos condiciones producen ese efecto de
malestar en el trabajo es muy
frecuentemente si tal yo diría que en mi
comprensión la fuente mayor de malestar
el trabajo del día es el no
reconocimiento pero sobre todo en el
reconocimiento derivado de la relación
de competencia la otra singular es no
estar haciéndole tú no le gusta a veces
incluso las personas experimentan una
vida muy satisfactoria porque tampoco
estudian lo que les gusta yo he tenido
que decir muchas veces personas que
quieren estudiar una carrera como la
psicología pero vienen de la ingeniería
y no dicen qué le pasaba no pues que yo
creo que eso lo que tiene que hacer
porque el nuevo médico que es ahora no
porque haya ganar dinero o porque mi
papá tiene una empresa ingenieros pero
la verdad son algo que yo quería y en
efecto cuando les aportó el final tuvo
que cambiar
tenemos entonces que el reconocimiento
es una variable muy importante
necesitamos dos tipos de reconocimientos
cuando hacemos el trabajo las cosas
sencillas es pura ley de newton cierto
atracción de una reacción a toda
contribución hecha al trabajo una
retribución digamos
reconocida como contribución simbólica
el reconocimiento de este reconocimiento
es entendido de estas dos maneras uno
toda persona que trabaja necesita que le
digan que cambian lo hizo justo para que
trabaja necesita que tan útil es eso que
hizo esas dos cosas son fundamentales
y
este programa que les planteo sería lo
único que es posible pensar alrededor de
los que están experimentando el mundo el
hogar contemporáneo es tan nefasto esto
que estoy diciendo para hoy no podemos
pensar que algo se podría hacer y lo voy
a decir si hay algo que se puede hacer y
siempre podemos ser mejor aquí lo que
está en nuestras manos después uno que
no podemos cambiar el capitalismo y
tampoco la forma era del trabajo
contemporáneo flexibilizado pero si
además de algunas cosas que están en
nuestra hermana y que son sencillas por
un lado tenemos la posibilidad
de hablar de nuestro malestar conversar
es una forma de gestionar el malestar a
veces tenemos que hacerlo con persona
fuera del trabajo a veces lo podemos
hacer con un compañero
en contra del sentido si usted está
haciendo una cosa que no tiene sentido o
se le encuentra cierto verde piensa como
la redirección aparente resentido o
simplemente busque una actividad que en
efecto tenga ese sentido para usted
digamos el que le da valor a lo que hace
buscar infatigablemente cierto si no lo
tiene renuncie si eso no ha mostrado que
usted quiere busque otro perdón a tiempo
que declararse allí porque lo veo que
podría pasar es que le produciría
constantemente la experiencia de su
malestar otro récord de la solidaridad
en el trabajo consiga un amigo esta vez
que una relación de solidaria con la que
usted pueda digamos tener el mínimo de
confianza para poder hacer el trabajo
mejor y compartir más un último
reconozcamos los mutuamente es muy
sencillo cosas como saludar a agradecer
exaltar el que lo ha hecho bien o pedir
perdón al que hemos afectado no sería
más que darle la oportunidad a otro de
sentirse reconocido
te ha hecho lo más elemental y a veces
más difícil sonreír
la grava entonces está en la pasión la
forma en la que podemos exorcizar el
malestar pues trabajar lo que te
apasiona en lo que está comprometido tu
deseo lo importante es que hemos
descubierto que la gente que trabaja lo
que le apasiona generalmente lo hace muy
bien por cómo le apasiona generalmente
lo perfecciona como lo hace muy bien
generalmente también lo busca mucho y
por lo tanto entonces también se destaca
y como se destaca entonces también gana
dinero la clave entonces para tener un
alma la obra es más feliz y próspera
estar en aquello que te apasiona no hay
ninguna duda sobre esto
el mensaje adentro sería si quiere
experimentar la vida laboral que sea
mucho más satisfactoria trabajar lo que
te apasiona y no negocios es gracias
[Aplausos]